but having someone stand in as friend or
loved one isn't just a Hollywood fantasy
anymore as Adriana Diaz shows us people
in Japan are now paying for imposters
rui-zhi ichikawa runs something called a
rental family company and business has
never been better
for a fee he and his staff will
impersonate your parents your boss even
your spouse have you ever been
discovered and they were never it might
sound strange but each no Kawas business
was immortalized in a 2012 documentary
called Renta family Inc
he says his business helps clients
navigate the tricky norms of Japanese
society why is there so much demand for
renting fake family members okuni a new
home while Japanese obsess over
etiquette manners and appearances a lot
more than Americans do he said for my
clients not violating protocol is
extremely important he recently posed as
a pregnant woman's father because her
real dad disapproved of her engagement
she says he saved the marriage across
town another rentals in progress Hamas
for $10 an hour a proudly unhip
middle-aged guy will let you vent and
offer his worldly wisdom this time
self-proclaimed old fogey taka Nobu
Nishimoto is serving up life lessons
today
it's dating advice the shamoto sees
clients almost daily proving
over-the-hill is underrated boo-boo
clunky Audino cottage because I'm a
total stranger that clients can unload
even deep dark secrets he told us
they'll say I can't breathe a word of
this to anyone I know in Japan's unusual
rental universe sometimes the services
are provided on four legs instead of two
at Tokyo's dog heart shop patrons pluck
down cash to hang out with oodles of
poodles
beagles and the Golden Retriever named
Rika what that me see the Cuddy data to
the Japanese are uncomfortable about
borrowing things like a dog or a car
from a friend said owner Yukiko sukhiya
so it's simpler to rent from a company
delivery worker Yoshida Yamaguchi is one
of her most loyal customers
he travels an hour each way every month
to get his canine fix a new thought
playing with dogs is relaxing he told us
it gives me energy to get back to work
for the pet deprived and the status
obsessed the lovelorn and the confused
in Japan at least you can rent for that
for CBS this morning Saturday Adriana
Diaz Tokyo I love this I wish I could
have rented different parents at high
school if only we had that back then you
imagined it that's a lot of work being a
stand-in though I would think so yeah
the skills would have to be really
really good mariette death